NARRATOR: Before he
concluded his broadcast
with RT Television
Network in 2013,
former Canadian Defense Minister
Paul Hellyer publicly urged
officials to reveal the truth
about extra terrestrials
overseeing earth.
This information is
top secret in a way
that the governments
aren't talking about it,
but if you listen to the
whistleblowers and the people
who have worked in the industry
and who know what is going on,
there is just a lot of
information out there,
and it doesn't take very
long to get your hands on.
The future of the world depends
on us knowing what is going on
not only in our own
world, but in others that
are monitoring us and
attempting to influence
us for better or for worse.
And there are people here
who know a lot about that.
This idea that there are
other entities, whether
from other dimensions, other
galaxies, other planets, who
are actually
controlling or somehow
influencing what is
happening with life on Earth
is fascinating.
And we always have to ask that
question, what is their agenda?
Is it benevolent?
Are they here to protect us?
Or is there another agenda?
Is there an agenda
to control us?
to influence the way
that we live in a negative way?
So you have to wonder if
there is in fact some kind
of extraterrestrial council
that's watching over planet
Earth, that they are here
to look at our advancement
and to warn us of
possible catastrophes
that may be occurring.
And hopefully, we will
heed their warnings.
If we're being monitored by
extraterrestrials, if they're
watching human affairs, I think
they would be very concerned
about things that we might do
that would destroy ourselves
and destroy the planet.
And perhaps part
of the alien agenda
is our moral
development as well as
our technological development.
Perhaps this is our ticket to
join the Galactic Federation.
We might never know
their ultimate purpose,
but if this is an experiment,
we should be very, very careful.
Because quite clearly if they
don't like people challenging
them, well, we are doomed.
NARRATOR: If there are in fact
nine extraterrestrial entities
overseeing Earth, are they here
to help us as ancient astronaut
theorists suggest?
Or could they have a
more sinister motive?
Perhaps the answer
will only be revealed
when they make
contact once again,
and when we are more
ready to accept the truth.